Soderstrom:
I'm Gustav Soderstrom,
and I'm here to demo
Spotify for Android.
So Spotify is
a streaming music application
that lets you access basically
any song in the world
just as if it was
on your desktop.
So basically you can
just pick a song, play it,
and if you like it
you add it to your playlist,
and you keep building
these playlists.
You don't actually
have to download music,
which also means you can
share music very easily.
So let me
show you quickly.
Here's a Spotify client
for Mac.
I'll just type in K.
Search for any track
that starts with a K.
Let's see...
So I'll type anything
from maybe Superchick.
I can see, you know, all the
albums that Superchick ever did.
They're in Spotify.
Now I can listen to a song here,
like "Courage," for example.
[Superchick's "Courage" plays]
You can see
it started very fast.
I can seek
within the song.
Go to another place
in the song.
I can switch songs.
Like that.
So it's almost as fast
as if you had
all the music in the world
on your desktop.
And this application
is available,
not in the U.S. yet,
but it's available in Europe.
And let me just
pause the music for you.
You can use it for free;
it's an ad-funded version.
That means you will hear ads,
like, every 20 minutes.
Audio ads, actually,
and visual ads.
Now, by far the most common
request from our users is,
you know, they think this
is great, they use it a lot,
but they want--
they want the music
in their mobile, right?
So this just doesn't cover
all the use cases.
So what we did
was we sat down and we--
instead of just
quickly building
a streaming application
for mobile,
which would have been
sort of the easy way out,
we just sat down
and figured out, you know,
what should mobile music
really be like?
And what we came to
was a few things.
So there were two things
we wanted to do.
Of course we wanted to give you
access to any song in the world
at any time,
anywhere.
And we do that.
If you have a good, you know,
3G, Edge, or Wi-Fi connection,
you can just search for a song
and stream it wherever you are.
But there was another use case,
you know, the use case--
You're in the subway,
you're on a train,
you're in an airplane,
or you're roaming,
where, you know, this just
wouldn't be very useful, right?
So what we did,
which is unlike most other
streaming applications,
is we also allow--
We built
a synchronization paradigm,
which means that you get
the same playlists
on the Android phone
that you get on the PC, right?
Of course.
And you can stream it, but you
can also highlight playlists
on the Android phone
for download.
And actually it downloads
these playlists
locally to the memory card;
it encrypts them,
and then you can listen to them
in flight mode, right?
And you get, like, 10,
12 hours' worth of battery life
because it's actually
local on the device.
It doesn't
use the Network.
And what happens
is if you do changes
to these playlists
on your desktop,
as soon as the device
comes back into connectivity,
you know,
wifi, 3G, et cetera,
it's just gonna synchronize
silently these changes,
and download
all the new tracks, right?
So let me
show you that, actually.
So this is
the Spotify client for Android.
Now, as I said, obviously
I can go into search here.
I'll type in,
maybe, you know, L.
Search for any song
with an L.
So...
Actually, I like this one.
L'Amour Toujours.
So I click it, and you see
it starts really fast, actually.
I can do seek
within a track like this,
and just let it go.
And it continues
from there.
I guess you can't
hear it very well.
But it is streaming.
I can just go
to the next one in the list.
You can see it's almost as fast
as the desktop client, actually.
So we have
that use case
if you happen to have
decent connectivity.
Now what I think is really cool,
and a defining feature,
is actually
this use case.
So you see
my playlists here.
And if you look
at the desktop down here,
you can see
the same playlists here.
So what I'll do now,
if you film the phone, there,
you can see, for example,
like the Gustav playlist there.
Actually on the desktop,
I'm gonna move that around--
and you can keep
filming the phone--
I'm gonna move
the Gustav list up top.
And you can see
it just pops up there.
And now, actually,
I'm gonna change the name
of the Gustav playlist.
I'll just type in,
like, maybe...
I'll just type in
some crap.
And you can see
it updates to that.
So it really is
wirelessly synchronized, right?
So this is
connected to the cloud,
and the phone
is connected to the cloud.
So the other thing
you'll notice here,
there's a button
saying "Offline Sync"
And if I press that button,
you can see I have checkboxes.
So I've already checked a few,
here, like a good chef.
I pre-prepared
a few playlists here.
They are locally synced
to the memory card, right?
So what happens now--
If I add a song
to one of these lists
that are checked
for offline sync--
So I'll go to my PC here.
I'll...
I'll do a search for whatever.
I'll find a song here.
Let's see if I find
something interesting.
So I'll take this song--
A Front 242 song,
which I like,
and I'll drag it and drop it
under this playlist.
Actually, I dragged it
in the other playlist.
I'll drop it
in the top playlist.
And I drop it now.
And what you can see
happen here now
is it got a push message
that there was a change,
and it starts
downloading it.
And this happens
in the background,
when the phone
is in your pocket, right?
So it takes
a few seconds to download.
I can--In the meantime,
you know,
I can actually
go and play other music.
I can go around
the application.
I can go and check out
what's new.
These are recent albums
that we launched.
I can actually play music
in other playlists.
Just to show you
the speed of this.
And what happens
is, you know...
Yeah, you have settings
and stuff here as well.
Now...
So now it's finished.
You have 14 songs
instead of 13.
So what I can do now,
which is really cool--
I'll just go
into airplane mode here.
And you can see here
it's not connected anymore.
And I can still
play these songs.
So I'll go in here,
and I'll play
this Front 242 song
that we just
added, right?
And I can go back and forth
through this playlist.
Just as, you know--
Just as your
regular mp3 player.
So it's kind of
the best of two worlds.
It's the best
of streaming,
but it's also the best
of the synchronization paradigm.
The big difference is, you know,
unlike your current mp3 player,
you don't have to carry your
laptop and USB cable with you.
You can leave that
at home.
'Cause it doesn't sync
towards your computer,
it syncs towards the cloud,
which is a big difference.
So a few things
about Android.
The reason we chose
to develop for Android was...
It's--Instead
of everyone else,
it's an open platform
that we like.
We did some
investigation,
'cause actually this application
requires a lot of performance.
It--you know, it downloads
music in the background
at maybe 10 megabits per second
if your wifi is good.
It encrypts that
to your memory card.
At the same time,
you're streaming music
that should not
be interrupted.
At the same time
you want to have
smooth scrolling
through long lists.
It's quite
a challenge to do.
So we investigated
Android,
and were really pleased
with the performance it got,
so we decided
to do this for Android.
And what we've done,
which is pretty--
pretty unique
for this project,
is we actually used
our C++ core libraries,
using a native development kit
that is open source
that Google released
a few weeks ago.
So we built
the UI in Java,
but the core library
is actually C++--
the core
performance libraries,
so all the encryption and all
the playback and all that stuff,
which is why we got
such a good performance.
So the other thing
that I like about Android,
which is
pretty obvious,
it allows you to play
in the background,
so it really gives you the full
use case of this device,
and it transitions nicely
between, you know, wifi and 3G.
So it really supports--
supports the--
the use case of the application
when it did really well.
cameraman: Excellent.
Well, thank you, Gustav.
That was a great demo,
and a lovely explanation
of the Spotify application.
Soderstrom: Thank you.
cameraman: All the best.
Enjoy the conference.
Soderstrom: Thank you.